[forest noises]
NARRATOR: In rainforests
across the equator,
most frogs lay their
eggs and abandon them.
But one determined frog
stands by his young,
the reticulated glass frog.
It's named for its
transparent skin.
His organs hard at work,
he's got nothing to hide.
Mom is nowhere to be found.
Dad alone guards the clutch 24/7
until the eggs become tadpoles.
Sometimes this means
defending his brood
from their worst enemy.
Squadrons of carnivorous
rainforest wasps
take to the air, a
deadly threat for a frog.
They're aggressive, persistent,
venomous, and nearly as big
as the glass frog himself.
They're not interested in him.
They want his eggs.
But dad is not willing to
give them up without a fight.
He was built for this.
[music playing]